les profs les profs nous connaissent je
n'ai pas considérés comme des numéros
faire leurs études à nevers ces jeunes
n'y voit que des avantages et ce qu'il
souhaite c'est pouvoir rester dans la
cité ducale mais pour l'instant rien
n'est moins sûr et ils s'inquiètent
on nous a dit l'année dernière que si
notre l2 ou vrai et si on était en l2 à
nevers y aurait pas de souci on pourrait
continuer achèverons notre cursus et
puis ben finalement là depuis le début
de l'année on nous dit non on ne sait
pas pour l'instant peut-être que votre 3
ne va pas ouvrir donc pour nous c'est un
petit peu compliqué d'autant plus
compliqué qu'il devrait aller à dijon
pour y valider la troisième année avant
de revenir poursuivre leurs études en
master à nevers une absurdité pour ces
jeunes et pour le maire de la ville
denis curio c'est tout à fait légitime
quand d'enseignement supérieur il y en
est délocalisée voilà par justice par
équité par économie aussi les turcs qui
sont là ça leur coûte moins cher d'aller
dans des grandes villes
et puis qu'on arrête de nous dire il ya
le principe d'égalité ils n'auront pas
d'enseignement physique 6 en visio ça
dans les amphis fans tout le monde ne
tient pas il ya déjà de la vision le
recours à la visioconférence c'est l'une
des solutions envisagées par
l'université de bourgogne où l'on n'a
pas attendu de recevoir la pétition des
étudiants pour réfléchir à l'opportunité
d'ouvrir ou pas une troisième année de
licence de sciences de l'éducation à
nevers pourtant de mettre en place les
choses on peut pas dire oui on ouvre on
ouvre en septembre pick up et qu'on est
pas d'enseignant à mettre en face que
la technique pour faire enseignement à
distance ne soit pas opérationnel donc
voilà il ya un minimum quand même de
garantie sur lequel on doit avoir des
assurances pour dire ce ver en nous la
halle 3 une réunion sur le sujet avait
justement lieu ce mardi en fin d'après
midi au rectorat pour que les futurs
professeurs des écoles bénéficient d'un
cursus de formation complet dans la
nièvre